سلاح الجو الامريكي اعلن بدء العمل على
خطط لتطوير القاذفه الشهيره ب 52 لتتمكن
من البقاء في الخدمه حتى عام 2050
الترقيات الجديده ستشترك فيها شركه رولز
رويس وبوي وستشمل الخطه التي من المنتظر
اعتمادها قبل نهايه العام الحاليه استبدال
محركات القاذفه الامريكيه الاشهر في سلاح
الجو بمحرك من طراز اف 130 بتكلفه تصل الى
نحو مليارين و600 مليون دولار
صفقه جديده بين شركه البستانس والقوات
الجويه الاسرائيليه بقيمه 180 مليون دولار
لتدريب الطيارين على طائرات اف 16 حيث
ستوفر الشركه مراكز تدريب ومحاكاه
للطيارين الاسرائيليين للتعلم على كيفيه
التعامل مع جميع الاسلحه الحاليه وكذلك
ايضا في بيئات القتال المختلفه من المنتظر
ان يتم تسليم مراكز التدريب خلال ثلاث
سنوات كما تضمن العقد خدمات التشغيل
والصيانه لمده 15 سنه اضافيه
رصد تقرير وانشطه الفضاء السنوي لعام 2022
تخطي الصين لروسيا في عدد الاقمار
الصناعيه والتي تم اطلاقها خلال العام
الماضي وكذلك احتلال الصين للمركز الثاني
عالميا بعد الولايات المتحده التقرير الذي
اعده جون فان ماكدويل عالم الفيزياء
الفلكيه في مركزي هارفارد في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه للفيزياء الفلكيه اشار
الى تخطي الصين لامريكا وروسيا في عدد
الاقمار المخصصه لمهام دفاعيه حيث تملك
الصين 45 قمرا لاغراض دفاعيه مقابل ثلاثين
للولايات المتحده و15 روسيا التقرير حارس
ايضا على الاشاره الى احتماليه امتلاك
الصين عددا اكبر من الاقمار التي تعمل
لاغراض عسكريه بسبب تعقيم بكين وحرصها على
سريه معلوماتها